can you guys break down this
um this mbappe situation yep so
basically uh al-hilal is the Saudi team
and effectively
yeah I think that's the name of the team
oh hello but uh or halil and basically
they are what people call Sports washing
in Saudi Arabia where they're buying up
all these major players they bought
Cristiano Ronaldo so now they offer
mbappe a billion dollars so something
that was popularized around the uh
Olympics okay where these like big oil
states were essentially like buy up I
think it was like weight lifters from
like Georgia yeah and be like yo you're
gonna get citizenship here and you're
gonna weight lift for Qatar yeah and
then Qatar gets to win a gold medal and
I think also maybe the idea because I
heard it once and I forgot details but I
think also it changes the perception of
yeah hey look at all these human rights
atrocities too oh this is the place
where all the great Pro players the
World Cup yeah it just puts you on the
map right like people really care about
sports especially around the Olympics so
like even just seeing the flag go up you
start even asking questions like what's
guitar like what is that oh what's going
on what the purpose of changing the
public perception from yeah you know
either nothing or an evil oil state or
whatever people's preconceivable yeah
okay so now they offer a billion dollars
to get mbappe for one year
yeah you you pay the team a little bit
of money to like hey we're taking it
team has the rights and then they'll
sell your rights and then and then you
pay the guy salary so he gets 775
billion million and then the team gets
250 or something like that yeah and he's
basically in like the prime of his
careers like in his mid-20s he's like
already won a World Cup he's one of the
most prominent young soccer players
potential ghosts yeah like taking over
like now Messi and Ronaldo are kind of
fading out of like the uh National stage
he and like Holland are taking in so
it's going to be him and Holland for the
next 10 years yeah basically is what it
looks like and so the question is does
he leave one of the elite leagues in
Europe which historically I've always
dominated the French league is like less
dominant people will argue than like the
English leagues the Spanish leagues or
even the Italian leagues so does he walk
away from that does he not go to Madrid
not go to some other like prominent team
and like really Earnest stripes and like
cement his legacy is one of the greatest
players ever or take 750 million dollars
play one year in Saudi Arabia against
whomever is in the league at that time
playing with play with Ronaldo for a
year
get your money get your money bro hold
up hold on one second just real quick
PSG as the team is currently on haven't
they been demoted
or something are they no longer in the
no they're still in the league one they
well are they still in the what is it
called Champions League champions is the
champion that's like the the tournament
amongst all yeah are they still in the
Champions League so you qualify for the
Champions League each year I don't know
if they qualified last year I'd have to
check and does that okay so that
wouldn't affect this season I'm trying
to wonder like if the team that he was
going to be on isn't even qualified for
the Champions League he's kind of
playing they lost Messi but they still
have bikini I'm assuming they have other
good stores I know they got they had
those three hakimi's [__] nice yeah
Neymar Neymar yeah yeah and then there
was this rumor that came out that like
the deal was already done with Real
Madrid with mbappe yeah so clearly he
wants out of PSG oh this is what it
seems like just this applies they washed
out of the Champions League last season
and then again this season as of they're
not in it so they're not in it and
that's the only way huge Factor that's
the only way you can see the king of
Europe if I'm if I'm I'm going I don't
want to play in a subpar league and not
get those Champions League games because
that's less goals that I'm going to be
able to score that's the last
International Spotlight like that's less
competition at the highest level I gotta
go to some other team that is going to
play
I mean Real Madrid makes perfect sense
that's what I'm saying going to like a
Madrid playing in Spain what would that
offer look like I have no idea I'm
actually curious I can look it up
definitely and I know yeah because
comparing those offers would be helpful
so that's the other tricky thing right
is that it's one year of your life
absolutely you know how often a player
is injured and misses a season you could
treat this like an injury season yeah
like you play one year there you get
775 million dollars now the thing that
America did with Messi is they found a
way to make him the equivalent amount of
money yeah as the Saudi League offered
through Equity uh opportunities to buy a
team later and getting a piece of all
the different uh emergency
they're like we're going to give you a
piece of everything and it'll look so
far like that [__] is going to work out
yeah right yeah so the question is can
is it even worth it to Spain to offer a
crazy deal like that for uh mbappe it
might be worth it for League yeah League
might come together and be like let's
figure this out which country has the
most beautiful trans women because I
think that's gonna factor into this
decision I think he should play for a
Brazilian Colombia or something
Colombian yeah yeah yeah in fact the
fact that none of us said Thailand is
crazy like Thailand really fell off like
they started that [__] yes and then they
just got left they've been wrestling
under Laurel dude they really have been
resting for the rest of them they
thought that they didn't have to do [__]
they need a better Rebrand because they
call them lady boys you get boy out of
here what's a boy that's a lady that's a
lady that's a lady bro come on now
yeah apparently Madrid was speculating
to offer 200 million for like a six-year
deal get the [__] out of my
compared to the Saudi deal because it's
not even that's never happened at like a
billion dollars for a year and even as
just a competitor I just realized this
how do you brought this up how does
Ronaldo identify himself as still being
Elite he got like 400 million for two
years hey bro I got 700 million for one
year I got you hmm you're not Elite
anymore I'm the guy if you don't take
this off the pot you said he shouldn't
do this yeah I don't think she does why
well one I don't even think it's a real
offer like I feel like they are throwing
money around to get the attention of all
the other players in Europe because you
could with that money with a billion
dollars if you think they the most I
don't even know what the max is but like
I think realish got like 300 million
it's like something crazy and that was
like the most ever to do what to go to
band City I actually don't know what his
deal was but like the precedent for
these deals this is like three times
like what the biggest deal before was so
I'm looking at this like they're
throwing around money they could make a
top five team with just a billion
dollars you know what I mean like they
can make a not just one player you need
more than one player to make a team you
could get the you know starters from Man
City from man united from all these
other teams pull them in and create an
actual good team to compete on a
national what about that makes this
unreal not real because I'm assuming
that they're just throwing this money
around to get people's attention this is
a bat signal yeah you it's it's the uh
what is the the where uh what's it
called when our boy pbd said I'm gonna
pay you 100 million into Tucker yeah
whether or not Tucker accepts that
everybody looks at PVD and goes damn my
man got a hundred million they got
something serious going on again but if
Tucker signed a 100 million dollar
contract he still gets 100 million
that's what I'm saying but they're
thinking if he signs it we get the best
player in soccer yeah if he doesn't we
get the attention you got Draymond Green
no real deal but yeah none of that means
he shouldn't take the deal they believe
that he won't yeah but even if he does
they get the best yeah and if he doesn't
the marketing that they're gonna get
Draymond Green is out here going yo do
they have basketball teams on LeBron
said it Jana said it so this is like
it's a great PR now here's the thing I
think if he doesn't take a deal like
this it's not the best PR move because
it makes it look so awful to live in
Saudi Arabia for one year that you'd
rather not make 775 million dollars
that's funny right like in a way it's
just like
I would rather lose half if imbabwe goes
I would rather lose half a billion
dollars
then there's a year in Saudi Arabia yeah
the reason I don't think I think that
they didn't think he was going to take
it first off because there's already
like this is from PSG reportedly offered
him like a billion dollar contract for
like a lifetime deal so like in my mind
he's gonna make a billion dollars
regardless you know what I mean like
whether it's through contracts with his
clothing with his merchandise with
whatever team he plays on he's only like
20 something you know what's the
difference between two billion dollars
and one billion dollars that's a billion
dollars but I'm like a billion dollars
plus Legacy you know what I mean like
he's going to become one of the greatest
players of all time
you know Jordan sat out of here with a
broken foot right that's what I'm saying
it's an injury you've got to look at
like an injury and I'm like I think that
affects his legacy no it doesn't no why
not because I think Michael Jordan you
don't think he would have scored more
points if he played another year but
does it affect his legacy does it affect
his statistics he's got so much
second greatest player of all time
because no even if he's the greatest he
would have been more great if he played
another year but he's the greatest but
he would have been more great but you're
the greatest so did you even know did
you have anything exactly because it
doesn't affect his legacy we won't know
about it later on is what everybody's
saying is at the end of the day as long
as he continues to have success like he
has had right then and also it's like
the things that are interesting about
him Bob is he's already won the World
Cup right yeah and he scored three goals
in the finals loss yeah
I mean like
You could argue that the legacy is is
there I mean it's not yet he's got a lot
of work to do but what I'm saying is he
gets to go I've already won the World
Cup that that is checked off I never
have to do that again we're good to go
if I win another one
I mean oh my God and if we win three
which is potentially possible you could
play 12 more years he's 25 right now
something like that yeah 37 might be
tricky oh no maybe that's what the
advancements in like anti-aging [__] I
don't think I think all athletes are
going to start playing longer fair
enough but it is very possible he plays
at least two more World Cups at an elite
level yeah
so he is the opportunity to maybe win
another one there if the team is the
French team is good enough and it looks
like it is pretty good like point 24. he
is 24. yeah so bare minimum he's gonna
play so be 35 36 from the next World the
Third World Cup happens yeah
very reasonable I don't know I
understand you want to go after it and
it depends where Holland's gonna be and
what he's going to be doing and you
won't be in the conversation I mean like
you know Ronaldo went out there and he's
just a ghost twick we don't even know
he's alive like yeah he's playing in a
half full Stadium didn't even like win
the championship yeah but that doesn't
matter he went there to retire right
yeah he's just gonna take that one yeah
let me get my money because you're gonna
remember he's back next year and if a
career ending injury does happen he's
got 775 million dollars yeah but if your
goal is to be the greatest
again this is unaffected one year ago
said if he gets a career any injury like
if that could happen in PSG too yeah
but he's not doing it through something
that seems like negligent his career you
know what I mean like well you could
also make the argument if you want to be
the greatest he wouldn't have signed a
PSG
yeah but he started with them like he's
been with them and just re-up the
contract right so now he's stopping the
contract now they're not performing are
you a fan of PSG
yeah he is I like that I'm not like a
Die Hard fan though yeah
but he likes France
that's why he wants him to stay here I
get it I would too something he's French
in France it's kind of like be the king
of your country oh no get the [__] out
get the [__] out of France
he should have left PSG a long time ago
you go to the English Premier League or
you go to La Liga in Spain and that's it
and be dominant and be the greatest ever
and then make a billion dollars yeah 10
other ways I mean if you really want to
dance you go right up there where
Holland is and you join the [__]
competitive uh whatever the their
biggest [__] competitor is yeah
whereas Holland on man city so you
joined [__] Manchester United and you
just go to war with that [__]
yeah I mean that would be crazy